les anciennes guerres la guerre froide
la guerre contre la terreur on savait
contre qui on se battait
mais aujourd'hui l'ennemi est invisible
la menace est une clé de décryptage elle
peut à filtrer n'importe quel système
sécurisé de la planète
la posséder c'est pouvoir contrôler
n'importe quel pays à distance vous avez
une mission je vais avoir besoin d'être
n'est pas venu juste pour prendre des
nouvelles je vais monter une équipe
était la meilleure au monde dans son
domaine
et où est le paquet je veux pas que vous
pour le papier toujours dans la nature
et j'ai besoin de ton aide pour la
retrouver tout le monde est après cette
arme qui étaient là tu peut l'identifier
marie schmitt
agents du pnd
[Musique]
tu sais quoi sur le disque dur ou alors
tu as des secours proposé dans flingue
s'il vous plaît agathe39 les i je tirais
ou alors écoutez moi
on travaille tout pour des services
secrets différents américains
britanniques allemands colombien chinois
mais aujourd'hui nous avons un ennemi
commun la seule solution c'est d'unir
nos forces
la partie n'est pas finie
[Musique]
ok on a assez joué
vous avez des caméras dans vos collier
des micros dans vos boucles d'oreilles
la moitié d'entre eux est recherché par
la cia s'il met la main sur la clé c'est
une guerre mondiale assurée
[Musique]
on est les 355
tu crois qu abandonner et toi non
[Musique]